[Music]
on today's show we talk a lot about
trauma we talk about trauma after a
hurricane we talk about trauma after a
hard car wreck
we talk about trauma of letting foster
kids go
how we deal with it how we loved stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what up what up
this is john with the dr john deloney
show where we are dancing and singing
and checking out james new khakis
because boy he loves talking about those
and we hope you are doing well
if you're the first time to ever listen
to this show you brought on who james is
or anything about his khakis
and you're better off for it this is dr
john daloni show where we talk about
mental health and wellness
and relationships and parenting and
education and everything and sometimes
we talk about james pants james is the
producer of the show and
god almighty's always talking about how
cool well the records show that i'm not
wearing khakis
man talk about making the show weird
what are you wearing you made it weird i
did i'm sorry
man the number of times i've heard that
in my life no you made it weird you're
right
kelly are you wearing khakis
i played the fifth
are you really that's so cool how cool
i've got my uh
corduroys wow 84. that's cool good to
see you
that's the year you were born dang
grandpa nick yeah sorry that's here i
was born yeah kelly just froze her brow
sorry grandma kelly
you're not that much younger than me
um i disagree when i said you made this
weird i didn't mean this episode i just
mean from day one you've made this
i love it so my wife says about our
marriage like john you made this so
weird it didn't have to be weird
all right hey listen a few
months ago
i said
you if you will
you as the listener if you will email i
mean if you will
write me letters
with poems in them i guess i did a poem
about james i forgot this i did a poem
about you james and i think it was
remarkable and i asked people to mail
letters in
good god almighty you sent letters in
i've got stacks i'm like a mailman now
the guy that sits next to me ken was
like what is happening over here it's
like a it's like harry potter like that
owl just drops things down all the time
except there's no owls that's what makes
it even weirder um but we're gonna do a
mailbag here so i'm gonna read some of
the letters you sent in i hope you
we're serious
um
this one's really long i won't do this
one sorry if this was somebody's
like
they really meant something they've
accepted your poem writing challenge get
ready
i'm presenting you the greatest poem of
all time
here it goes
come on man
thanks heidi the poem is
james is super rad
kelly carries yourself with poise
the doctor john dolone show is my
favorite fan
forever a fan as my favorite forever a
fan of the horse noise
heidi you totally redeemed yourself
there at the end feels like a win-win
for both of us there i think we all win
kelly as always you lost all right let's
see here smoke's on a stick some of you
all sent in notes and you all need to go
to therapy now like right now
don't stop go don't collect 200 and if
you don't know what that is you're too
young
all right here we go
hey john i accept your challenge here's
my poem
obviously i can't write poems i don't
remember the stanza rhyming rules there
is no rules
and please consider a simple man by
leonard skinner for being the best song
ever written
i will take that into account thank you
so much
all right
this poem is entitled delony
delony delony he never talks baloney
told you kelly he shows up to teach us
how to love
every time i listen i feel like a
special dove
yes
when he says best song ever written
i am even more smitten is this a love
letter are you gonna kill me at the end
of this
carry on brother john to help us all
have a special bond when our time is
done we will know you helped us make a
difference in so many others existence
now
go outside and play
dude joanne
brought some smoke and you didn't even
mention james and kelly which is cool
we'll do one more this one's written
like a serial killer this poem's
entitled john it could be about a
commode or me
john are you listening
john is that a horse i hear
listen good folks five bucks stand up
move forward what does that mean john
stop counting
we are here community your people poem
for john
i'm a super fan
thank you for being you kelly and james
too good jobs all thank you
i don't think you need therapy but you
need a morning
drinks you should start drinking earlier
i don't know when you start drinking but
it should be earlier thanks to everybody
for your poems
dude these are gonna get awesome but i
need you to screen some of these holy
smokes
whoa
that might have been my favorite segment
of the whole show what's that this is
gonna be my new favorite thing on the
show
here we go
hey dr john i was listening to an
episode of your show on july 28th to the
introduction you challenged listeners to
write your poem and mail it with a stamp
i decided to check accept the challenge
here's another haiku
i wrote a poem it's bad
i've got 10 billion hours to improve
nick
nick
thank you
i'm gonna be sitting in a deer stand
sometime in the middle of the winter
trying to decipher this poem and you and
your 10 billion hours
thank you nick i'm going to publish
these we're going to publish all of
these
whoa
whoa all right let's what should we do
on this
show
maybe take the first call all right hey
let's go to john in one of my favorite
places on the planet home of louisiana
what's up brother john
how are you doing dr d i'm all right hey
listen homer um
some of my favorite memories of my life
are in home louisiana
some of the greatest crawfish
greatest shrimp
greatest fishing trips of my life i had
some loved ones it's what an amazing
small community i love it right there on
the bayou it's awesome
so you actually been here oh yeah hey
can i tell you a funny story but it's
gonna sound like i'm mocking people at
home and i'm not can i tell it to you
oh yeah sure
so we're fishing and i caught this
gigantic turtle
it was like on my fishing line and we
got it in and wanted to like take care
of it it was just this big red ear
turtle
and i know people i've eaten snapping
turtle i love snap turtle soft shelter
this is just a big old like red ear
turtle
and i got the hook out of his mouth i
got some pliers and
if you ever tried to deal with a big
turtle trying to bite you too and they
got a hook in their mouth and it's a
whole thing
and
so we get it off and the turtle's just
staring at us and so i take my foot and
i don't kick him but i'm i'm just edging
him back into the water
in this man he's he he probably he
looked like 111 years old but he was
down the bayou from us and he just goes
in that in that french accent
and he comes running down the bayou boy
brother kicked our turtle and he took
the turtle and he just took it home to
eat it and i remember thinking this is
home of louisiana it was incredible it
was incredible it's one of my favorite
places on planet earth i love it man is
that is that where you're born and
raised
yes sir oh good for you man what a great
community so brother how can i help man
well
i think you know the big question
um we just went through hurricane ida
down here yeah you did man
um
and
it really affected this i mean more than
houma and thibodeaux and terrebonne
refuse parishes and
but it
i it's just hard to describe i tell
people
people talk to me i said i think i'm
having a little bit the meeting question
is that i think i'm suffering through
survival guilt hmm tell me about that
and
okay
that's the first one and um basically
what it is is that
i got i had to stay
because my mother-in-law who we live
with
says i'm not evacuating so then the wife
says i can't leave my mom
and
i said well i guess that means i gotta
stay
yes that's hey that's the home away
yeah it it it is down here and i mean
she's 77 so she
she's just really setting her ways and
now granted i knew where we lived at
i wasn't have to worry about storm surge
because we live far enough inland but i
knew we were having some issue with some
wind and stuff because we had a huge oak
tree in the backyard that's right
and i had a real stress hat
so
let me stop you right here and i think
this is important for the listener to
know
this is going to come out a month or two
after
the hurricane hurricane it has run
through
and
we live in a click bait culture
this was a big deal we watched it on the
news all across the country everyone was
checking in on hurricane hurricane
hurricane and by the time people are
listening to this we've already moved on
to the next kardashian thing the next
kanye west thing the next
um
whatever tragedy happens to be
and the people at home of louisiana are
still walking outside trying to figure
out where electricity is they're trying
to figure out how to put that big piece
of tin back on their roof or keep the
tarp on the roof because the insurance
adjusters haven't come out there's real
people still living in this stuff
and
as a guy who did crisis i always showed
up after
the media was leaving
and you're sitting with folks who are
thinking
how do i
like everything in my life is in tatters
how do i put this thing back together
um and so man john i appreciate you
calling and for the listener i never
want people to forget the human beings
left in the wake of these things
there's always humans these aren't
headlines these aren't clicks these
aren't
and then on to the next thing these are
people living in these moments so john
you all wrote it out you stayed through
and then tell me where you're at now you
got survivor's guilt what else man
yeah and
actually managing
my tempo
and i guess the frustration level um
is where
i guess like the big thing like he said
everyone's doing the clickbait thing
they go there and they
say poor new orleans or
poor jefferson parish and yes they think
they did get hit i'm not saying they
didn't
but where if anyone followed the track
of the storm it came up those lower
river parishes and bayou parishes and
a lot of people are angry about that
because they just don't see it yeah but
then also
you're dealing like with us we have a
few people that came stay with us and
you get you're not used to them
you get that little aggravation when you
don't do something exactly what like you
like to do
yeah yeah
or your family or your family is giving
you 10 000 things to do with a device
yeah
you're trying to go okay guys um i'm the
one who stuck down here and
and most of my family did evacuate
and then when he was saying well we
wanna come home and i'm like i'm telling
my mom don't come home yeah we have no
hospitals that they they shut down the
hospitals we have no water
power's still not on and you want to
come home and you are elderly
stepdad is elderly y'all both have
conditions
don't come home yeah this is i've never
seen anything like this yeah
during katrina i was an offshore worker
that time so the day after the storm i
had to go out there and do jacket
inspections so what they call an rov
operator right
and so i was checking on the auto rig so
i never got first-hand experience of
really seeing the depth station i saw
like everybody else did on news or
whatever we got
driving around my town in the
surrounding areas
oh my god this is it's a war zone huh
i think that's what i told you all in
the email this is a war zone i mean this
is oh i don't even i didn't even read
the email i didn't know but yeah i've
i've i grew up in houston man so i've
seen these things and it's it's
it's just it's mind-boggling every day i
went to a different section to try to
help someone out or something and i'm
seeing new damages i'm seeing buildings
that have been up for all my life and
they're crumbled yeah
it is just
i mean we're fortunate now um the good
news is
power has been getting restored slowly
but surely my neighborhood probably
won't get power for another two days but
we do have a backup a standby generator
so we're doing okay
like i said and that's where the
survival guilt comes in i mean i look at
what we add i have this old house that i
lived in that we're living in
and we really didn't suffer that much
damage hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on
you're doing it like a good tough guy
will do it
okay yeah and i i know a lot of tough
women who do this too but i'm just
talking to you my brother in houma
i don't care how bad somebody else had
it
or how good somebody else had it
you
went through hell
and you were scared
and everything you know is different now
oh yeah
there was a level of uncertainty and a
level of there's a level of this is the
way we do it in houma and that same
thing by the way is the way this is the
way we do it nebraska this is the way
kansas people respond and this is the
way texans respond and new yorkers every
every small geographical region has
their ethos their way of doing stuff
and when you drive through your
neighborhood and it is leveled
these places where you went and played
where you had fun where you kissed your
first girl all those things are gone
or
or and or
we just don't ever have a a a concept in
our head of
a day without electric like
the electricity can just go off there
can just be a place with no hospitals
and you get to see what so much of the
other world lives with on a daily basis
oh man this is a gift right
and it's scary so listen
i don't care how bad somebody else has
it
you
get to own your grief
comparing your grief to somebody else
doesn't make them feel better
it just takes your pain and squashes it
and you know where it comes out in anger
and it comes out in frustration and it
comes out in anxiousness and it comes
out and not being able to sleep
and so the first thing you got to do
here how old are you
54.
54.
you've seen a lot you've been through a
lot you're a good man who loves his wife
who takes care of his elderly parents
and his elderly in-laws
you're a good man
thank you and i want you to sit down for
a second by yourself
and breathe deep
and cry your eyes out
i want you to exhale and get out a piece
of paper and just jot down
i'm hurt and this was scary
and we don't have any hospitals and i'm
worried about the future of my town of
my community of my parents of all that
stuff
and your body is gonna
roll out of fight or flight which it's
still in
every time you drive around your
community it's there you're running and
gunning you've been on adrenaline and
cortisol for the last week last two
weeks right
you're buzzing buzzing buzzing buzzing
buzzing at some points you got to come
off that
and you got to sit down and let your
body know i'm here and i'm present and
i'm heartbroken and i'm sad and that
that ash
that is the soil that will grow the new
trees
that's the soil where healing will
happen where then you will then
gather the strength in the community and
the resilience to say are we going to
stay here we going to move are we going
to rebuild are we going to ride it out
like what is this going to look like for
us
comparing yes it's so frustrating that
new orleans gets all the news i get that
worrying about that and being angry
about that is poisoning your body hoping
somebody else will suffer does nobody
any good
right right and i know it's like man
everyone's forgotten about us you
haven't your neighbors haven't your
community hasn't the media has and since
when we start listening to those folks
man they're off
you know what i'm saying i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna give them that power in my
life
i'm not going to give them the power to
fire off
my cortisol and my adrenaline and my
fight or flight and my cytokine response
i'm not going to give them the
opportunity to cause inflammation in my
body that's going to make me die younger
i'm not giving them that power
what i'm going to do is i'm gonna love
my family
i'm gonna keep driving around my
neighborhood and finding ways to serve
i'm gonna go to work and work hard as i
can
and i'm gonna grieve this thing because
it sucks it's heartbreaking
right that's where you're at
and that's been good now honestly it's
been a good thing the last three days
i've been at my church
volunteering and unloading trucks and
giving out food and supplies and stuff i
wish more people in the world were like
you
well
don't be a homo louisiana 54 year old
man say thank you okay say thank you i'm
a good man
i'm thinking i'm a good man there you go
you are
yeah i mean i got called back to work
that's where i'm heading to you right
now and so um
um but you're right i am grateful and i
am grateful that i survived and i am
grateful that i'm seeing this because i
can now get a better perspective how
most of the rest of the world lives and
some of these conditions
in addition to being grateful
you can be heartbroken too
i want you to spend some time being sad
because this is sad
i don't want you to blow over this i
don't want you to try to white knuckle
this i don't want you to snip into a
slim jim i'm gonna crush
you gotta take some moment to grieve
this
i can't be a normal man and tough it up
no
no cause you're gonna die like one
you're right you're right and there's a
reason tough guys lead the world in
heart attacks and strokes and
organ disease failures and addiction
because we're like
okay
you gotta take it and process it and if
you're a real crazy guy
you can go sit with your wife and hold
her hand and say can we just go sit on
the porch and be sad for a minute i'm
heartbroken about my town
and she may say
she may not even know what to do she may
just
she may just start crying out of sheer
joy or she may call you a wimp i didn't
marry know a softy guy with his feelings
and you can look at her and say
hey i'm heartbroken here
right believe it or not believe it or
not
we've been doing that good i do i do
exactly what you say touch the face yeah
yeah look at that
listen you didn't even need to call me
brother you are
a good man your community is so lucky to
have you your family's lucky to have you
what i want you to do is to own your own
the
the crap of this and then here's the
magic man
when you look and you see that just
swath of devastation
right that those 100 year old trees are
knocked over the 200 year old trees are
knocked over and the buildings are
flooded and they're condemned and
there's no hospital
here's what it is
it is i'm going to take a series of tiny
steps and get through today
right and then tomorrow i'm gonna get up
i'm gonna take the small steps that i
need to do tomorrow
and i'm gonna challenge you to get a
note card it's what i carry around with
me and just say here's what i can do
today
i can go to work i can check in on my
mom and dad i can check in on on my
mother-in-law
i can check in on my wife
i can run over to my church and serve
that's what i can do today and then
you're gonna cross those suckers off
and you're gonna keep a gratitude
journal just to remind yourself what
you're grateful for you're gonna get up
tomorrow and do it again and here's what
will happen over the next two three five
six months
home is tough
thibodeau parish is tough
y'all will
rebound it'll look different y'all are
all gonna be different
but you're going to stand up tall again
the
the sun the sun's already out it's hot
those mosquitoes that are as big as
crows are already flying around right
they'll be there the fish will come back
right you will you will stand up tall
but it's gonna just gonna take a series
of tiny steps to get there and i want
you to have that note card that you pull
out every day because you can keep track
of your progress and things are gonna
feel like they're spinning out of
control they're not moving fast enough
you can control john's little steps
every day
right yes sir and last thing
you got another guy in your life that's
your age you can just holler at you and
go sit down
yeah one of the guys i work with good
please make sure you do that and y'all
can talk crap and politics and make up
dumb jokes and whatever and make fun of
people that that's what you do i want to
make sure you got somebody that's not
your wife that you don't feel
responsible for for owning right uh not
owning but for you don't feel
responsible for their care right
that you can just sit down and unload
with
someone that you love and someone that
cares for you
sounds good but listen to me brother
i as just a
guy live in the united states we see a
lot of nonsense on the news man so much
nonsense
and what i know is there's more john's
out there than there are not
and you have restored my i'm smiling
right now man because of you
a guy who loves his community loves his
neighborhoods out there serving he's out
there
we'll do the hard stuff and sit on his
porch and just be sad with the woman he
loves he's going to grieve this on his
own he's going to go reach out and talk
to people and he's gonna take care of
the tiny little things he can do every
little day those little steps i can't
try to solve the world i can't turn the
hospitals on get all the power back up
tomorrow
but i can go move some boxes off of a
truck
i can make sure i'm moving my body i can
make sure i'm eating some of that
crawfish and hey if there's a little boy
that catches a big turtle and cook that
up too
that's what you're gonna do right
i'm so grateful for you john thank you
so so so much for the call we'll be
thinking about home louisiana and that
swap of the world
don't forget the humans down there and
if you've got some time if you've got
some energy some resources make sure you
are looking those folks up and taking
care of them they're struggling
struggling struggling
but they're going to come back
especially if we all come back together
stay tuned we'll be right back on the dr
john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we're back let's go to grace
in grand rapids
michigan
what's up grace
oh not much how about you you know i was
gonna say we're saving the world but
we for sure aren't
um
i'm running a middling podcast over here
in nashville tennessee but i'm glad to
be talking to you what's going on
okay so
um
about a month ago
i
woke up to knock on my door from a state
trooper saying that my husband was in a
car wreck
yikes what happened
he was on his way to work and
a woman blew through a stop sign
and got him pretty good
oh man i'm so sorry
so where where is he at now how is he
uh
at the time he was in critical condition
which is
something nobody wants to hear
um you have little ones
yes we have um
three little ones five and under so it's
pretty busy around here grace i'm so
sorry
yeah
um
he has severe brain damage due to it
okay
um
he is currently in a nursing and rehab
facility
right now to
try to get him back on his feet
as much as possible
is he awake um
he is awake
um does he have speech and eye movement
and auditory and sensory stuff his eyes
movement is getting much better and they
just started speech therapy with him
this week okay does he recognize you
when you're there
we think so
um he especially will try to move his
mouth when his parents are in the room
and grandparents
and especially the kids that was
when the kids came to visit him that was
the first time he actually was crying
um you know that's a really remarkable
sign right
oh yes
yes um
there's so much even just in little
things that
god has been showing that
uh he's still here for a reason you know
we keep hearing he should have died
he should have died on the operating
table he should have this but he's still
here
i'm so sorry um so how can i help you
today i'm so sorry
man thank you
um
[Music]
the biggest thing right now is
it's gonna be at least two to five years
hopefully
before he comes home
there is a possibility he might not come
home again
the kids have been
wondering when daddy is coming home
especially our oldest who's five
i know they're going through a traumatic
disappearance just the fact of daddy not
being there
and i'm just wondering how
to help them in
oh
that
man oh man oh man
i'm so sorry grace
thank you
so
there's a lot here and
if you and i were just talking in person
i'd probably spend the next 10 minutes
just in a hug
um
who's walking alongside you with this do
you have family do you have friends that
are connected with you guys in any way
so both of our families are pretty big
so there's probably a total of like 40
family members
alone
so you got the opposite it's like you
just need a glass of water and you're
getting a fire hose right
people have been coming out of the
woodwork we didn't even know existed
we honestly have more people taking care
of us than we know what to do with
and reports introverts so that's that
kind of makes it even more hilarious
so
people have been giving us meals and
asking what they can do around the house
child care
anything basically we needed
so um
i i think i've talked about this on this
show but um
my oldest and best friend on planet
earth um
was
one of his friends ran a stop sign was
hit by a car and
we spent some some
multiple days and nights sleeping on icu
floor and
went through the whole
tbi recovery process and all that stuff
and everything's different now 20 years
later everything's different and
we still obviously are in contact almost
every day but um
well i've never been married to anybody
i don't have kids that's a whole other
layer and level
that stunned
just
hit by a bus feeling that you have oh my
gosh my heart breaks
um
so when it comes to kids i mean just
focus on that one today and then i want
if you'll
if you're okay with it over the next
couple of weeks next couple of months
i'm going to keep checking in with you
um i've just been down this road and i
would love to just check in with you
okay and make sure anything you need um
you can holler at us and you're gonna
have more people around you
giving you
bonkers advice and telling you what you
should be doing and how you should be
doing it and all that stuff and
sometimes just having a neutral
person to call and just say what in the
world um
i want to make sure that you know that
we're always going to be here with you
thank you when it comes let me put it
this way um this is a month ago you said
yes okay
over the next 30 to 60 days
you're gonna be able to breathe again
and my guess is maybe a couple of days
here and there for an hour or so but my
guess is you haven't fully breathed yet
and when you hear things like it could
be two to five years there's a part of
you that where that registers and a part
of you it could be a thousand years or
hey we're gonna go to mars right for all
i mean
it feels like you're hearing some of
this stuff underwater
right yeah and then some days you
surface and you wake up and you've slept
a little bit deeper than you have and
you look over and he's not there it all
comes back like a giant tidal wave
and then you got three little kids that
you gotta feed and go to the bathroom
and they're asking questions like
where's daddy and i miss daddy and one
of them will just start crying and
yelling and then it becomes really hard
to breathe am i saying it about right
yes and i did have a talk with the two
oldest um that you know everybody said
right now just because daddy is not here
we all miss daddy we want him to come
back
and they have expressed you know they're
sad too because they miss daddy of
course um but they have a little little
album each pictures of them and daddy
playing and so they'll look through that
before they go to bed and it helps them
kind of
just seeing pictures of him comforts
them a little
um having them well so let me back out
one of the greatest things you can do
for them
is to tell them the truth
to not hide your grief from them don't
over share
but they're a part of this process with
you
and one of the things that we often try
to do is protect our kids and in a
situation like this this is trauma that
most people will never understand
when they cry we say it's going to be
okay and it's not it's not everything's
different
and when we cry we need to we go in the
other room
and
they feel crazy
if we do that
and so in the days that you cry and
they're in the room
put your arms out and say can you can we
snuggle
and though and you can just say i'm
missing daddy and that is a lifeline to
a kid
we've had lots of snuggles and they
definitely have seen me cry and they
know why they just say i miss daddy too
and i'm like yep
and the challenge here here's another
challenge
that they don't become
your comfort blanket right
they can't fill that gap for you and
sometimes it's they are the next closest
thing to him right and it's easy to make
them
like they become your support blanket if
you will and so making sure you've got
adults so the number one thing when i
when folks say what can i do for my kids
in a moment like this i tell them you
make sure you're taking care of you
that you're greeting that you've got
people around you that you're sleeping
that you're eating that you're going for
walks
that you're moving your body that you're
doing those things that are going to
keep your heart and head as clear as
they possibly could be while you're
trying not to drown in grief
right so we've made my sisters and
sisters in law have been making sure i'm
eating drinking and that they get
people around me when they're not there
so you're good
so here's the second thing
draw boundaries and do not apologize i
can't tell you the number of people who
i've talked to over the years who have a
loved one pass away or in a car wreck or
they get a cancer diagnosis and their
full-time job becomes taking care of
everyone around them
making sure they're all okay right
and
you now know that
you have become a beacon to other people
your husband's become a beacon to people
that y'all love that life is fragile and
it can go away at any moment and you can
just be driving to work and somebody
runs a stop sign and it's all over right
or that life turns on a dime
and people don't know what to do with
that and they need you to make them
feel like it's all going to be okay
and i need you to hear me say that's not
your job
your job is to take care of you and to
love your kids
and so when you get 8 000 texts a day
you can feel free as a bird to respond
to none of them
zero of them you don't owe anybody that
you don't owe anybody um thank you notes
for their meals you don't owe anybody
you know i mean like i'll come over and
clean up your house or mow your you
don't know anybody that
you owe you the opportunity to begin to
process this and heal and you owe your
husband
just a hand to hold right now and your
kids and your kids and your kids does
that
i want you to feel as free as possible
to set strong boundaries and say thank
you and then go on and
accept the help
yes that's that's been the most
difficult for me because i'm the giver
not the receiver so all this has been
very humbling there we go games change
now sister right
so if someone wants to mow your lawn
rock on mow it somebody or you know
what's awesome you're gonna have one or
two family members who are like super
uber go-getters you can sit with them
and say here's what i need you to do i
need you to schedule lawn care for the
next year
and they will you know that'd be such a
gift for them and you can tell i don't
want to cook for the next 11 years
set it up and they will be like yes
they'll get a spreadsheet out every
every family's got that person right um
you can give them that gift and that you
are gonna have to learn just to say
thank say thank you and say yes i need
some help i need some help with some
laundry i need some help with my kids
does that make sense
yes actually his aunt has been in charge
of the meal train and child care getting
that scheduled and my father-in-law has
been
taking care of
just anything that needs done around the
house getting
everything on autopay for bills and
setting up things and all that stuff so
great great great great great great
great how are you guys financially for
help and i know how to how to deal with
how are you guys financially
we are okay um we had that three to six
months
of expenses saved
and
because so many people have been so
generous we have not touched that at all
great did you have short-term or
long-term care insurance
that is in the works as we speak but he
your husband had that at his employment
yes okay fantastic so so good what a
gift
um i've been in these situations where
someone's got to go to work on monday
and that's such a gift good good good
good good
all right here is the last little piece
of advice i'll give you
okay for in this again this is all free
so you can you can hang up the phone and
be like well that was a waste of 10
minutes of my life
i want you to practice not feeling
guilty for smiling
and i want you to practice not feeling
guilty for laughing for taking the kids
out to dinner just y'all for
for going to a movie just y'all for
you're gonna feel guilty that you're not
including parents and grandparents and
cousins
you're gonna feel guilty that you're
doing these things and it's going to
feel like you're quote unquote moving on
while your husband's in a hospital bed
you're going to feel guilty when you've
got to pick up all three kids and you're
going to miss one of his pt appointments
and i want you to decide now
i'm gonna be at full
at peace
with
trying to however difficult and ugly and
brutal it is
if i see a flower growing up to the
sidewalk i'm gonna stop and acknowledge
it because it's beautiful
if something's funny in my house i'm
gonna laugh i'm not gonna feel guilty
about it just because my husband's not
here okay
the guilt and shame machine will get up
and going in a wild wild way
so i want to make sure you have a
journal of some sort and if i were you i
would overpay for it i'd go get some
fancy pants leather bound something or
other
and i would start a series of letters to
my husband things he misses like when it
just pops in your head a funny joke an
old office episode whatever it happens
to be
when you reach over in bed and he's not
there
i want you just to write that down reach
for you tonight you weren't here i miss
you
and um
how does something hilarious happen
today i missed you
i ruined dinner again and i can't even
warm up leftovers right
and
you would have laughed at me and you
weren't here missed you
had an awesome day at pt today and it
was so good to see you
i have been writing those things down
and
just so that when he is actually able to
read again he'll have something
to look through
and i want your children to to draw in
pictures
children process thing through play
through writing stuff down through
coloring you can color daddy a picture
and maybe that becomes a thing you'll do
once a week or twice a week we're all
going to color daddy a picture we're
going to make them uh um you know get
some grass and gravel i don't know what
kids do they come up with crazy stuff
and know that your five-year-old's gonna
have different memories than your
one-year-old right
oh yes those are gonna be different the
one-year-old is gonna he's gonna be
abstract he's gonna be this floating
presence that was sort of here and not
here
and then six months from now it'll have
been you know almost half of that young
child's life where dad wasn't here our
dad was just that guy in the hospital so
every kid's gonna have different levels
of memory and it will be different for
everybody right
don't put expectations don't compare
your grief don't say well it could have
been so bad now this is hard and awful
and heartbreaking yeah right
don't be very lonely without him here
so lonely
and then his shoes are over there in the
corner and his stupid shirt still wadded
up in the bathroom right it's all still
there
and there's those days it's so
comforting to see that stuff and there's
those days that it is
it is so heartbreaking to see that stuff
right
yeah who knew actually doing his laundry
would be so hard yeah you know
well it's always hard
it's always hard but it's a special
right especially right now
um
look those doctors in the eye
and tell them that you love them and
you're grateful for them
and passing on that gratitude where you
can is is a healing gift for you too and
just know you're going to be healing
from this
forever for a long time so you're not
going to try to outrun the grief you're
not going to try to outrun the healing
that's going to be little tiny steps
every single day
yeah
your kids are really blessed to have you
grace
and what an incredible family incredible
family
make sure you have non-family friends
that you can be angry with and cuss your
brains out with and scream at and be mad
at god with if you're a person of faith
that you can just rage through this and
you can cry with and you can laugh with
and go get pedicures with and all those
things
make sure you've got people to do this
with because grief demands a witness
and this isn't going to make sense for a
long time that's not really the goal the
goal is survival the goal is
learning how to breathe again
the goal is making sure those kids and
you are eating and walking and moving
and
the goal is holding that old man's hand
and the
the advancements they've made with tbi
is just something to behold and so i
would hold every bit of optimism and
hope that
two to five years becomes you know
six to nine months
that we don't know how long we don't
know how long becomes suddenly he sits
up and says i got a headache and i've
seen that a few times with with people
that i'm close to
so
keep out hope keep out optimism don't be
afraid of the grief don't feel guilty
for laughing
and we will be thinking about you grace
really thinking about you
stay in touch and we'll talk to you soon
we'll be right back on the doctor john
doe on the show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you it's why i
wrote this small direct and personal
book called redefining anxiety in this
book i discuss what anxiety is what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole and well listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right it is big bang theory times go
to sheldon in bellingham washington hey
sheldon what's going on
hey there dr john man it's uh
good to talk to you i really appreciate
your time better to talk to you you
never hear big bang theory jokes do you
never listen man my last name rhymes
with like a processed lunch meat i'm
with you
we're going to persevere through this
we'll get through it so what's up
brother how can i help man
oh man first of all my heart goes out to
great that grace that's uh that's hard
to hear yeah it's a tough tough tough
situation man tough tough tough yeah
yeah so what's up in your world man
so my wife and i we're foster parents um
we hey
hold on can we stop and celebrate you
guys what got you into fostering
uh i mean early on my wife wanted to do
it before we got married and i wanted to
adopt and so we met halfway with
fostering to start with
that's so good why are we doing this
because my wife wanted to but you did
too so good for you well man what a gift
you're putting out in the world i'm
grateful for you so what's up y'all are
fostering um
yeah we're fostering um got a little one
with us right now we've had several uh
short term and then another long term
one that's back with family now and
got a little one with us now that's
about 13 months old picked her up from
the hospital um
it's just you know heartbreaking to see
the whole family dynamic
but i'm smiling right now i'm so glad
y'all were there to pick her up that's
incredible
she's pretty incredible i tell you what
she is uh
yeah i don't know never been a big one
for little kids but my goodness i didn't
know that little kids could be that much
fun dude they will take your soul and
spirit from you man it's it's incredible
yeah it's awesome yeah yeah
so what's up um
so the one parent has basically
disappeared made it very clear to social
workers everybody my legal obligations
are done and i want nothing to do okay
other family member um
is living it's a very complicated
scenario living with somebody that is
filing for custody on their behalf
and that isn't allowing this individual
to not really go through any of the
steps to get their proper custody
and so what that means is if
the child goes into
this
person's care
then
this family member could just take the
kid there's no repercussions there's no
follow-ups no nothing the kid just
disappears
and
yeah as a foster parent you're powerless
yeah man
so
i have heard of this attempted
um
several of my close mentors were
um
attorneys or counselors in this system
i've heard of that attempted before i
haven't heard it be successful
it it might be whoops i just squeaked my
microphone here i've
i've
i've heard that attempted i've never
heard it be successful
because the person filing for custody if
they're just some random boyfriend or
just some random girlfriend
they have to prove a connection
and a dating relationship often doesn't
provide that connection
and yeah usually i see it some
downstream relative will pop out of
nowhere and say i'll step in but i've
heard this attempted but i haven't heard
it be successful have you heard that be
successful in your area
yeah and part of the complication is
this person filing for custody has the
half siblings these six half siblings of
this child in their care uh well then
hey that's i'm wrong there's a hundred
percent chance they're going to get
custody then
yeah and dad is not even fully blood to
these other kids okay another yeah it's
doesn't matter if
if there's half siblings there then the
court will sign that over in heartbeat
and they will call that a family
reunification and they will move on to
the next case on their overloaded docket
of people who refuse to take
responsibility for their children which
is just heartbreaking
so
yeah i mean she'll be the seventh kid
under 12. yep in that home yeah
here's uh
i'm just gonna tell you the truth okay
when you're in foster parenting and i'm
telling this you already know this
you are a bridge
and you help
hold suspended children
while the adults in their life who have
are not acting like adults figure out
what they're going to do
and
the word when anyone says i'm a foster
parent the first or should i be a foster
parent the first thing i ask them is
can you handle heartbreak
because that is the nature of foster
care
it's heartbreaking even in the best of
situations you've been living with this
little baby and holding her and taking
care of her and feeding her and laughing
with her and getting to know her weird
little cute 13 month old personality
and even in the greatest of situations
it's heartbreaking to hand her back
right
yeah and
in these situations
man
it's devastating
especially because you can't control the
outcome
so my challenge to you brother is to put
that stuff down because you can't do
anything about it
and you're going to make yourself crazy
trying to solve problems that you can't
solve
gotcha
that sucks doesn't it
yeah yeah
and the real challenge here is
can you keep your heart open enough
to go level another little kid
and i want to tell you as a foster
parent how many foster kids have you had
uh she's a second long-term placement
but we've had probably
20 kids in our home in the last
two years so you know this better than i
do man you know of course you do
but you know every time it's that your
heart fills up and then man it feels
like it's had the air taken out of it
right
yep is this one is this one this one
feels like it's uniquely painful for you
yeah i mean it was directly following
the placement of the last child and i
mean had a couple miscarriages and a lot
of failed adoption attempts privately
yep how are you and your wife doing
she wants a baby
and you want to do whatever it takes to
get her one huh
i mean short of stealing a kid
hey man if you got to do what you got to
do brother i'm just kidding don't do
that please don't steal a kid
when's the last time you all sat down
and looked at each other and made sure
y'all are still on the same page
oh two weeks ago and then the next day
we had a call about a possible adoption
that they needed a placement for
immediately and then it fell through due
to paperwork of course
yep yep we've had
numerous
issues of that nature yeah
so here's what's here's here's what i
need you to do man
number one
you're in love with a tiny little baby
girl
and you took her home for the hospital
and you've loved her
and
whatever her whatever her destiny looks
like it's gonna be different
positively because you and your wife
stepped into a gap that her parents
didn't provide
and as a member of
your community and her community i'm so
grateful for you guys and she is too
and there's some people gaming the
system
doing end of rounds on the system
and right now there's nothing you can do
about that you can get a lawyer and try
to fight it i guess i i can't imagine
you'd be successful because you're
giving a shot yeah though
yeah as a foster parent you have no
legal representation right
and so i tell you is to have a grieving
process with your wife where y'all can
walk through this and
and you also know the grief wrapped up
here man is bigger than just this little
baby girl going into a really tough
tough situation
it also is yet another opportunity for
me and my wife to have a family and what
we think is going to be with our picture
of a family
and we're not going to do that
and i couldn't
xyz and she could in xyz and there's so
much guilt here's what happens these
bricks in this backpack end up weighing
down your marriage to the point that it
makes it hard to keep driving and that's
why i want you guys to check in and
always keep checking in and always keep
checking in
because y'all are firefighters now and
you got to make sure each other are
breathing
because y'all are playing you all are
helping people in the most dire
situations but your relationship can can
you know where the where the scars of
those those interactions right
yeah yeah
if you can um i don't know what work
looks like i would love to see you guys
get away for a weekend and just control
delete and reset
and yeah i mean that's
yeah that's pretty easy i have a pretty
great work schedule i'd love to see all
you've heard me say this a hundred times
i'll say 100 times more
um
every time this happens
it's just like the twin towers falling
you can't take all that glass and dust
and steel and rebuild those same two
towers you got to excavate the whole
thing and build something else new and
create something beautiful and say all
right here we go again
i'd love to see y'all exhale and say
where are we what's it going to look
like tomorrow it's going back in two
weeks it's going to come up and
you're not failing anybody if you all
take a break
at some point you got to put on your
oxygen mask first brother
and i know it feels like well if we take
a break that could be the day of the
call that could be the co y'all can do
that until you make each other crazy
and it may be time for a break 20 kids
22 kids and a couple of hard heart
breaks and some miscarriages in the last
24 months is a lot of trauma
yeah
well yeah i mean miscarriages were
before the
24 months that hasn't these guitars
either
um
yeah go for it
do you have any advice on connecting
with this parent or the possible person
that would be taking placement of the
child
i always um slade sullivan is one of my
most one of the most important men i've
ever known and they have been foster
parents and adoptive parents
and they
were the ones that
him and his wife taught me about the
importance of reaching out to family
members
sometimes it's a no-go
but sometimes
the parents were really
open to
here's how to be a good mom here's how
to be a good dad here's what this baby
loves
and so being proactive and not being not
thinking i'm the best
but i've loved this little baby right
now and we could teach you guys they may
say you know what y'all screw off we
don't need you that's our kid
or they may say oh that'd be incredible
we would love that
and so
again you're setting yourself up from a
heartbreak for sure but i am always
always gonna lean into that and i
watched um
slade and his wife do that and it was it
was extraordinary they'd you know decide
his wife would go to coffee with these
moms and talk about parenting and what
love looks like and
really remarkable things and so yeah if
if you have the stomach for that in the
heart for that i i think that would be a
remarkable thing again this is all for
that little baby right all for that yeah
yeah
and you may get rejected again right so
what are you gonna do um yeah
yeah and it may be time for a break i'm
not going to speak into your marriage
but i do i definitely think it's time
for y'all to step away and say
where are we
and you to make sure you look her in the
eye and hold both sides of her face and
let her know
i love you and i'm in this with you
what's tomorrow going to look like and
she needs to say the same thing to you
too thank you so much for loving that
little baby girl for loving your wife
for loving those kids
oh foster parents y'all are heroes
heroes heroes heroes heroes incredible
incredible incredible
man oh man man
man oh man man
kelly i don't tell you enough
you and your husband are good people too
y'all been down this road also
your husband's really great on multiple
accounts but
i even i have to agree with that one yes
as someone who only has to deal with a
few hours of kelly a day
whoa just kidding he's a lucky man
[Laughter]
man
do you have anything you can pass along
with sheldon i mean you've walked this
walk
not no because we have it in the same
aspect if we never had to deal with
birth parents yeah or anything like that
um
it's hard huh yeah the only thing i can
say is because i ran the adoption
ministry and foster administrator our
church for a while is
that
given the situation they're going into
there's a distinct possibility this
child's coming back out again yeah
and
be there
um
one of our friends this happened
probably 12 times that the child came
out over a number of years and every
time they took
took her until finally the mother said i
can't do it anymore
and they now have adopted her and
and they have a relationship with the
mother too
so as hard as that is every time they
had to leave
but every time and they knew she was
going to come back out again
back into the system and they just
picked her up and took her back every
time keep those doors open huh yeah so
that you can do it so hard and then you
know like you said be the one that
stands in that gap for that parent or
for that baby because
maybe they grow up with
two great families yeah exactly or they
always have a picture of
there's a point when a teenager
recognizes
it doesn't hap my parents whoa right
even in the best case scenarios parents
or kids recognize that
but there may be that moment when the
kid goes wait a minute that's what this
could look like all right and a foster
parent is who has stuck with a kid over
over a number of years gives him a
picture of what parenting and love and
showing up and connection looks like not
just i mean it's just worth its weight
in gold right as we wrap up today's show
this literally is one of my favorites
this is like my top three or four or
five and i think i've said that enough
to where i think we have 14 songs in my
top three or four of all time but
this is back from the 80s
the la guns this incredible song called
ballad of jane and it goes something
like this
let's tell all 80s metal guys this is
every rose has a store and it goes
something like this no it goes exactly
like this because this is the song right
but this is the ballad of jane and it
goes something like this she
was always something special
a diamond shining bright in the rain and
everybody dreams of angels and no one
will ever know how much i love your show
so
and now it all seems funny kind of like
a dream that things ain't always what
they seem what a shame
what happened to jane
and you were always on my mind the
child-like summer days in the sun and
slowly wishes turned to sadness
time doesn't heal a broken gun and i
wish i'd never let you go
hear me now because i want you to know
it all seems funny kind of like a dream
and things ain't always what they seem
what a shame what happened to jay
right here on the dr john dolani show